make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking up with dc's infinite
frontier now for those of you guys who
don't know what infinite frontier is
this is kind of the next official
move of dc comics future state was not
necessarily that it was an interlude
right so to give you guys a better
perspective
if the events of death metal was like a
giant movie
then future state was like the
intermission right where like you go and
get popcorn and now that we're back in
our seats continuing the movie we're
picking up with infinite frontier that's
essentially what this
is and so the idea here is this
initially picks up with wonder woman
right in the aftermath of everything
that had happened with regards to
the deaths of like perpetua and the
batman who laughs the reformation of the
timeline and the multiverse which is to
say
the idea that like the multiverse has
kind of been rebooted over the years and
all that was basically done
uh so now like everything that's ever
happened in the multiverse has actually
happened all the crisis events actually
took place but instead of people
forgetting about what happened after
those crisis events now they remember
everything
right so in essence it's kind of like
what the new 52 should have been like if
new 52 never happened uh how like
everything sort of would have progressed
right i guess the best way to think
about it but wonder woman here is
ultimately met by the arrival of the
quintessence right the phantom stranger
the specter
these people out there who sort of
embody these differing powers and are in
effect the higher echelon of beings that
exist out there right so um
the the hierarchy of dc comics in recent
years has really been
in a state of flux that we still have
beings out there like the presence who
is in effect god lucifer morningstar
like gabriel the angel michael like we
still have those guys out there
but one of the things that we've
consistently reiterated here is that
when it comes to dc's landscape
regarding like their angels and demons
and that kind of pantheon of power
that while it does consider itself
inclusive in the hierarchy of dc
comics you never really see them cross
over with like the main dc
superheroes right so with the exception
of like eclipso who's like the
embodiment of god's wrath
you don't really see and really the
specter i guess you don't really see
like
lucifer showing up and facing off
against the justice league or the
present showing up and saying justice
league there's a major crisis here we
gotta go face off against it you never
really see that right but they are part
and parcel to the entire dc landscape
therefore they are taken into account
with regards to the hierarchy
but as far as the main dc landscape goes
with the various superheroes the
quintessence are the most powerful
beings out there in the multiverse
that's leading out again all the other
pantheon of gods and stuff that you see
with like lucifer the presence and so on
and so forth those guys are beyond the
quintessence right those guys powers are
way beyond the quintessence but as far
as we're concerned these are the top
dogs here and because the fact that
wonder woman
has kind of designed to be this kind of
living force by which the multiverse was
more or less recreated
uh that she's offered a position among
the quintessence now what this would
mean is she would just
enter a higher state of entropy and she
would not really have any involvement
with any of the main dc characters it's
something that they would do
if they felt like just shuffling wonder
woman off to the cornfields so this is
something that would definitely happen
if it were a
lesser character right if it was
somebody like alan scott the green
lantern
or if it was like jay garrick or if they
were wanting to get rid of barry allen
and just replace him with wally west for
like years to come then they would throw
them onto the quintessence wonder woman
kind of approaches this from like i
would
but there's a major threat like i was
told there was a price to be paid
for for essentially saving the
multiverse and bringing it back i don't
quite know what this price is yet but
i'm trying to figure it out and so the
result is that the spectre
travels with wonder woman to basically
move around the earth as it exists now
and then find out what that threat is
now the reality is that for us as the
reader this is a zero issue right so
it's basically just a way for dc comics
to kind of give us a tour of what the
stories are going to look like
it's a showcase comic is really all it
is and so one of the first things we see
here we're not going to cover every
single thing here because not
everything's relevant
or doesn't really have any useful
purpose and it wouldn't really give us
anything that we wouldn't see in like
issue number one of whatever those
stories are uh but i will run over like
what the issue relaunches are going to
be once we get to the end of this uh but
we initially pick up with superman and
superman kind of showing up here
is is facing off or at least you know
initially looks like he's going to face
off against this you know giant monster
only to be told that the day was saved
by a person that calls himself
shazadam and then superman's like no
you're talking about shazam and they're
like no no no he attacked this guy he
basically saved us he's like you
he comes and goes he does it quietly
doesn't really make a great big huge
stink and he's like
he calls himself shazam and that's when
that's when we realized that bleeding
cool was right for
one of the very few times they ever are
where it turns out that dc comics
is actually renaming black adam to
shazadam
have a field day guys
[Laughter]
the comments are gonna go bananas you
guys are gonna lose your mind in the
comments section i can already tell
cause it is kind of a dumb name
but but nonetheless go forward and do
your thing right i mean we're not here
to be negative nancy's we're here to
just kind of tell you guys what's what's
going on at the moment to make it all
make sense and to explain it all but
yeah like black adam and here's kind of
the cool thing that i do like about this
though because we haven't really seen
where the story from future state goes
granted the black adam future state
story is in the future right so it's
just a potential future of where black
adam would end up being
it looks like they're moving in that
direction of him essentially becoming a
good guy in future state he was more of
like a monk
if anything he really wasn't like a
fighter or anything along those lines
but
uh the important thing here is that
black adam is in effect turning over a
new leaf so it looks like it's also
coming off the heels of the end of jeff
john's shazam run uh where black adam
had basically joined the shazam family
right he wasn't necessarily an official
member of the family he still had his
own source of power
and so on but he was basically a good
guy and that looks like where things are
going that he is in effect becoming a
good guy here which is actually really
cool
i'm pretty excited about this uh what
this means for like the rock blackout
movie i have no idea presumably it's
because
you know he's gonna become a good guy at
the end of the movie and all that kind
of good stuff but the important thing is
that black adam is making his way to
becoming a hero right so obviously
black adam is not the threat they worry
about the next thing we end up doing is
moving to gotham city right we basically
have this guard kind of making his way
through the through arkham asylum uh and
as he gets to the cell of bane of course
his job is to check on the various
villains to make sure that they're
locked up as they're supposed to be when
it's 11 53 pm he gets to the cell of
bain and then basically finds one of the
guards
standing in bane's cell is dead right
immediately assumed it's vein right it
just goes
initially goes to attack vein only to
find out bane has been jokerized and
then
killed and so in effect this massive
attack goes on in arkham asylum where
every single person has been jokerized
but none of them are laughing right
they're all basically dead
the next thing it does following that is
it switches over to oracle which is good
to see the barbara gordon's maintaining
the role of oracle i love that character
for her if i were being honest
i wish that dc would find a way to blend
batgirl and oracle together so she was
basically doing like playing both roles
i loved it when she did it in the past
and i would love to see it brought back
it is kind of tough to do it's hard to
have her be like the information broker
and kind of like the eyes and ears
and everything everybody's doing and
then at the same time be batgirl right
like one role is literally the opposite
of the other so i don't really know
exactly how you make those two things
work together we do get huntress back
which is cool
huntress is here that's gonna be
interesting to see for those of you guys
who are batgirl fans i know a lot of you
guys out there
do enjoy batgirl i think becky cloonan
is the one who's writing this um i know
she's writing wonder woman so i'm not
entirely sure if she's gonna be handling
batgirl
i hope so because becky cloonan is is
ridiculously talented it's stupid how
good of a writer she is
but uh but ultimately it looks like
another joker attack is going on
and so ultimately have batman who
responds to this member of the arkham
security force and it's kind of like i'm
on my way
right like just stay on the line and
things kind of go from there so this of
course leads into a new attack by the
joker which i'm actually interested in
seeing i know there will be some
naysayers who are like we just
got out of an attack by the joker but
like i'm kind of excited like i'm pretty
excited to see
where this ends up going one of the
coolest things to come out of this and
this is where you actually get becky
klunen writing which i'm exceedingly
excited about is wonder woman and
spectre ends up transitioning to
themyscira now they go to themyscira
because of the fact that wonder woman
realizes her mother's still grieving
over her debt over her basically her
vanishing her perceived death that she
basically died to save the multiverse uh
and so what you end up having here is
that in the aftermath of wonder woman's
death
you have a whole bunch of women who are
here basically vying for wonder woman's
position right who were vying for her
spot
the top person looks to be a woman named
nubia who basically seems to be like the
most capable and strongest of all the
women
inside themschira and the most likely
person to take over the mantle of wonder
woman
and that that hippolyta is initially i
wouldn't really say against it
she's just kind of like you guys are
already gunning for my daughter's
position which is a little offensive but
at the same time the important thing to
understand here is that honor and pride
are exceedingly important among the
amazons and that
this show goes on and so while wonder
woman has basically
you know is believed to have been dead
the reality of this is that
themyscira still needs to send somebody
out there to fight on the side of the
justice league and to fight and to
basically represent the mystery in the
world of man
since they're now more on the global
space or more in the global space than
they were previously wonder where they
kind of open those doors so they're not
as cut off as they used to be now i
doubt now
i imagine that if themselves like no
after the loss of wonder woman we're
just not doing this anymore i doubt
anybody would really
be pissed off about that they'd be like
we kind of understand right like the one
time you open your doors to the to the
human world your daughter dies so like i
totally get that like you don't want to
do it anymore
the world would understand but wonder
woman is a mainstay of the dc comics
landscape and so you need even if it's
not necessarily diana prince yourself
somebody out there who's playing that
role and doing that thing right and so
ultimately uh
hippolyta basically puts the three most
likely women through a test
to basically you know present to them
the mantle of medusa right and the idea
is
only those individuals who are pure of
heart can look on the face of medusa and
survive the experience and so two of the
girls bail out
and nubia is just like whatever right
like if i end up entombed in this thing
that's fine keep the birds off of me but
somebody's got to play this role
somebody's got to be
the new wonder woman the result of this
is that when the box is opened hippolyta
actually gives nubia the crown to
themyscira and the reason why
is because hippolyta herself is getting
ready to leave the mascara
go out into the world of man and find
out what happened to her daughter
but somebody has to rule themselves
while she's away and that's the mantle
that newbie is taking now if i'm being
honest here the the requirement to be
the queen of the mascura
seems pretty low if all you have to do
is just be willing to face the mantle of
medusa but
the consequence of doing that is also
pretty intense that you don't really die
you're just etched in stone forever so
you're literally just entombed for all
eternity which is a pretty steep price
to pay
so i guess that kind of you know kind of
shows a sort of courage and conviction
that's necessary
for somebody to be queen but the the big
talking point here is also a girl by the
name of
yara and yara is is kind of like this
amazon of brazil
as they address her we don't really know
much about her there's not really
anything that's being revealed here this
is the first time we ever really get to
see her we do kind of see her for like a
brief moment right when she's talking to
her aunt and her aunt's basically
telling her
it's kind of the repeat of the wonder
woman story you can't go out there into
the world
it's too dangerous it's too scary we're
trying to keep you protected trying to
keep you safe yada yada the same kind of
stuff that you saw with the traditional
wonder woman story so while while it can
kind of go both ways in the sense of
like this is awesome that we're seeing
it at the same time it can kind of be
like
i've seen this story before give her
something a little more interesting it
looks like that's what we're going to
get
is again with becky clooney writing for
those of you guys who are a little
hesitant about wonder woman
becky cloonan's writing it so my general
rule i don't know if it really amounts
to anything my general rule when it
comes to becky cloonan if she writes it
i will read it and then maybe
maybe it's a story that i'm not a huge
fan of and then i'll stop reading it but
she's not one of those writers where i
look at it and right off the bat i'm
just kind of like
i don't know if i'll get it or not i
always read at least the first story arc
of everything becky clooney writes uh
and so from there you kind of again you
have wonder woman sort of traveling
around
kind of kind of bouncing from one
location to the next one of the cooler
things that that her inspector end up
doing is actually traveling to
metropolis to basically see the arrival
of a villain called the mock
now the maw itself is not the concern
here their concern is jonathan kent
right the jonathan kent is basically
taking on the mantle of superman now and
operating in metropolis which really
seems to give credence to the idea that
superman himself
that clark kent is gonna be operating on
a far more broad scale
and that he'll arrive to help jonathan
only when he really needs it whether or
not that'll play out we don't really
know because we know that after brian
michael bendis's action comics and
superman
was not great uh that a lot of work is
being done to revamp superman
and to change things so we don't know
exactly what new direction the series is
going to go in if it was brian michael
bendis continuing it i would just say
no they're probably gonna be fighting
side by side but it's a whole new writer
a whole new team they're you know what
they're gonna do with it we don't really
know they can just completely reshuffle
everything but the important thing here
is that based on future state we saw
that jonathan kent basically became a
bad guy when he became a villain
effectively a tyrant and so because of
that the big concern here is that that
will be his future right that that
future is guaranteed to come to pass
that's one of those examples of when dc
was talking about how future state was
something that may or may not happen the
reality is
what comes out of future state as
something that will eventually take
place in dc comics what elements they
will include
depends entirely on us as the readers
did we buy those comics were they were
they like really popular did they get
good reviews if it was a comic that we
hated and nobody liked
then like you're not going to see
anything come out of it with you know
it'll just be like well it was a
possible timeline and it'll just be a
hand wave
you know that's it it doesn't matter so
uh because of that with with
jonathan the spectre is super super wary
of him because when he flies headlong
into the maw he demonstrates a few
things that make the specter concerned
right to the maw
basically uses time and space as a
weapon and so to fly into
and attack the mock means to end up in
any point in time
and space there's no guarantee and that
while he does have the powers of
superman
at the end of the day he seems to be
headstrong and he seems to be
reckless and that's something that
superman cannot be that in being
reckless that is easy to also get
emotional right recklessness is usually
the result of a highly emotional state
otherwise you would be logical and so
because of that
because of that that issue that with
with jonathan kent having been through
so much over the course of his life
right being through instances where he
was whisked away
by by jorel into space and taking on the
taking on this kind of crazy mission
right and having a partnership with
damien wayne only to have it yanked away
you know in
in having it you know being tormented by
his father he was crazy in the future
you know spending a thousand years even
beyond that you know hanging out with
the legion of superheroes that in an
exceedingly short amount of time he's
gone through a
litany of emotionally struggling
issues and so because of that it could
easily turn him into a tyrant and so
what he ends up doing here is actually
flying through the mall
all the way back to the point where the
maw was when it was essentially
exceedingly young when it had gotten
lost from its own group or its own race
or what have you
and in that that in that feeling of
loneliness it became bitter and so in
that bitterness it somehow arrived here
after becoming a villain and just
causing pain and torment everywhere it
went
what jonathan does is take it back to
where it was originally supposed to be
essentially sealing the rift completing
the circle and of course the maw
basically ceases to exist right but it's
one of these things where it's kind of
like okay
like this is a scenario whereby jonathan
is doing the right thing
right he's showing empathy he's showing
compassion that's those are not the
characteristics of a tyrant and so it's
really dc kind of saying like hey like
will jonathan become a bad guy will he
not become a bad guy
stay tuned and find out i think this is
a terrible direction for him to go in i
just want to see jonathan hanging out
with damian wayne again
and having adventures and being fun like
i just want to see that right
super suns was probably the best thing
coming out of dc rebirth at that point
in time
and it sucked that dc cancelled it
because it was amazing it was such an
amazing story it was just good
old-fashioned fun
again they kind of bounce around here
one of the really cool things to come
out of here and this is something that i
really want to address here
is the character of kelly right kelly
was an awesome character that was
brought in by brian michael bendis when
he was doing young justice
young justice was one of my like was one
of my personal comics those guys who
don't know
there's comics out there that i just
never cover on the channel like i just
read them because i enjoy them and i
don't really want to make videos on them
because i feel like you know it's just
it's fun to have my own comic that i
read
just for the sake of me with you without
any kind of expectation that like i'm
gonna talk about it offer my thoughts on
it or anything along those lines i know
you guys are the same way right you guys
have those same
same comics on your own kelly was a
character who actually discovered a
person or really like an alien that was
dying that crash landed on earth uh that
had the ability to tap into the green
lantern central power battery
and that's why she has a kind of
equipment that she does but in doing
that she's not
truly a green lantern in the traditional
sense but she is able to manipulate
the willpower aspect of the emotional
spectrum the same way a green lantern
can't and so what you have here is jon
stewart and simon bass bringing her from
earth to
the guardians of the guardians of the
universe on the planet owa so they can
analyze her and decide whether or not
she's someone who can go forward
as a green lantern uh i will read this i
will i am
so reading this like it looks so much
fun
[Laughter]
it looks amazing i am i am so excited
for this like i i can't wait to see
kelly as a green lantern because
it looks like like her stories look like
they're gonna be amazing like they
look like they're gonna be so much fun
and the green lantern mythos needs this
coming out of like grant morrison's run
like it needs just like hey guys i'm
kelly i'm a kid and i got a green
lantern ring
like i need that i i need that so bad
because can you guys imagine
what her constructs would look like as a
green lantern it'd be
it'd be it'd be like the coolest thing
ever right you got like doomsday who
shows up on earth and here comes kelly
and he's just getting pummeled by like a
giant teddy bear
you know like you've been a bad boy
doomsday
i think it'd be amazing i think it'd be
hilarious and so ultimately
wonder woman is brought back to the
quintessence with you know basically
realizing the threat that she was
concerned of doesn't really seem to
exist and she's offered a role at their
side
and then ultimately turns it down right
and basically saying like what you guys
are offering here is a great opportunity
right to become part of the quintessence
this super powerful group of individuals
who are tasked with safeguarding and
overlooking the multiverse
and making sure that things kind of stay
in working order in effect but i have to
turn your offer down and the reason why
is because
earth is my home and those are my
friends and my family my job is to be a
superhero
my job is to to look at humanity and to
give them the possibility of a better
life
and so if that's the case if if ushering
them into a better future
is really the role that i was meant for
i can't do that here i can't do that
amongst you guys
and so ultimately she ends up traveling
back to earth and so now i'm
really excited to read becky cloonan's
run now here's the cool thing right
here's the coolest thing about this
the epilogue which is drawn by it looks
like john romina jr you can usually
always tell it's him
because the characters always look like
blocks right they they like it's lit he
literally just sketches squares
and then like they become arms and legs
it's uh i was never a huge fan of his
art style
the thing here is that you have the the
quintessence who kind of looks upon
what's called the omega earth right kind
of like the the
the or at least their their main base of
operations actually and talking about
like the the omega earth or earth omega
uh which is you know kind of like this
that we're really looks like they're
turning into a prison planet for various
people who are out there and are bad
guys but in essence these they're kind
of like this threat that wonder woman
was so concerned about
if she had joined us she would have
realized we already contained it right
so they were
they basically lied about there not
really being a credible threat out there
they lied but they didn't lie right
they're like obi-wan
right like many of the truths that we
see or you know from our own point of
view or whatever it was that he said
it's very much that way
that there was a threat out there that
wonder woman didn't need to legitimately
be concerned about but that threat has
since been quelled and it was quelled by
the by the quintessence because what
they talk about here is that with the
power they have
there's literally nothing out there that
they cannot control or defeat well then
suddenly this disembodied voice is like
die right and basically just kills the
entirety of the quintessence right
kills the whole quintessence only for us
to find out this is not just
dark side this is true form dark side
which is kind of ironic because true
form dark side was kind of like an
uh concept that grant morrison may or
may not have made up uh really it was
just a way for fan like true form dark
side was a fan
creation and it was just a way for fans
to try to find a way to justify how it
was
that dark side being killed by like
doomsday for example
didn't end the multiverse but darkseid
dying during grant morrison's final
crisis
resulted in the multiverse essentially
don right it was a way to kind of square
that circle and
basically say well that was true form
dark side right all the other ones were
just facsimiles of dark side and kind of
calling it a day it makes sense and it's
a smart move but this is darkseid in its
most pure form and even goes as far as
to say
all those facets of myself because the
multiverse has been restored
all those former facets of myself that
existed before crisis on defenders the
ones
the one that existed after crisis the
one that existed before final crisis and
and
after the new 52 but they've all been
absorbed back into me i'm more powerful
than i've ever been
i am the final version of myself right
so this is
in effect the true form dark side but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end uh let me
know what parts of infinite frontier
you're most excited about oh the list
that's right okay so in march of this
year
um we get action comics we get batman we
get batman superman
we get batman urban legends which is the
number one issue that looks cool uh
detective comics of course keeps going
on
catwoman is continuing the flash is
continuing harley quinn is getting a new
solo series
no surprise the joker is getting a new
solo series he hasn't had one of those
for like three decades so that's going
to be cool
um justice league gets a it's continuing
nightwing's continuing suicide squad
gets new number one we knew that was
coming superman's continuing the swamp
thing he gets a new number one
teen titans academy looks awesome i'm
excited for that
uh that's the number one uh wonder woman
is continuing on in april we get green
lantern number one which is cool
in may we get mr miracle the source of
freedom which is going to be a
i don't know if it's a one-shot or a
mini-series robin's getting his own solo
series
star girl is getting a spring break
special so that's basically going to be
a platform issue it's one of those where
it's like if you care we'll continue it
if you don't we won't there's wonder
girl
of course which is gonna be really
really awesome and then in june you get
supergirl woman of tomorrow which i'm
really excited about
uh and then in the summer you get
infinite frontier number one right i
have no idea what that's supposed to be
but it looks like it's gonna be really
really cool i'm excited for it guys but
anyway we're gonna bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you